(audience applauds)
- Please welcome Morena Baccarin!
(upbeat music)
I love you!
- Hi, I'm so excited to meet you!
- I love your make up!
- Thank you!
- Oh my gosh, you're so cool.
- Thanks, man.
- Oh my gosh.
- I have help.
- I'm not this cool by myself.
- Okay, well that kind
of brings me right back
to when
I saw you in, let's talk about
a few of your projects.
- Okay.
- If you don't mind.
- Sure.
- "Deadpool."
- Oh yeah, okay.
- Okay, you're so hot and cool in that.
- Thank you.
- [Drew] Any fly on the wall
moments from "Deadpool?"
- I will say, the second film,
I shot all of my scenes underwater.
And that never made it in the movie.
I was...
When I tell you in a
panic, like, I was panicked
the entire time.
And I don't scuba dive, I don't do well.
And it was like, it was
as if like, you know,
like it was probably another
10 feet above the ceiling here.
And when you're like, you know,
I think this was the
word for "I need air,"
and then this was the word
for "Get me out of here!"
(audience laughs)
I was always doing this,
and they'd like, "Okay,"
they'd have to like,
destrap me from the chair.
- 'Cause I'm sure you're weighted down.
- [Morena] You're weighted down.
- So that you're not floating up.
- It's terrifying.
- Okay, "Homeland."
Oh my God.
(audience applauds)
First of all, kudos to you,
you've got Mandy Patinkin,
Claire Danes, Damien Lewis.
Like, everyone doing their thing
and you come in there with your moxie
and just meet the moment.
- Thank you.
They shot the pilot with
somebody else, unfortunately,
and it didn't work out for
whatever reason, as the mom.
And I got the role and came in already to,
you know, a pretty gelled cast,
and the kids, they were like,
kind of putting me through
the ringer a little bit,
the kids.
They were like, "So,
"what's your name?
"Uh-huh, you think you
can just come in here
"and be our mom now?"
(audience laughs)
"Okay, let's see."
By the end of that day, we were besties.
- All right, give me a
fly on the wall moment
from the amazing show "Gotham."
- Oh, wow.
(Morena laughs)
(audience applauds)
That show
has a real special place
in my heart, of course,
'cause it's where I met my husband.
And you know, we shot
together for five years,
we became a real family.
I had a baby.
(Morena laughs)
That's him.
He wrote the last episode
that we ever shot,
and it was a scene where...
The very, very last thing
we shot after five years
was our marriage scene,
our characters getting married.
And it was, I'm gonna start
crying thinking about it,
but he like, he wrote
this beautiful speech
that Harvey gave,
that was very, you know,
sort of personal to us
and moments that really
resonated with our personal life.
Yeah.
(Drew cries)
(audience applauds)
Thanks a lot.
- That's so much even
better than fly on the wall.
Okay, tell me about "Endgame."
- Yeah, I'm so thrilled with how
they've been supporting the show.
I don't think you can be a human
in any city in the United States right now
without seeing an ad or a poster.
- [Drew] You turn and it's "The Endgame,"
with like, your sexy...
- Yes, the two of us, just like...
(audience applauds)
It's a joke in my family,
bow to the queen now.
So I play Elena Federova,
who is an international arms dealer.
Who has orchestrated getting
arrested, essentially.
So she can set in motion
with the fabulous Carolina Herrera dress,
that I found myself.
- [Drew] And it doesn't wrinkle,
which is really impressive.
- [Morena] No, it doesn't!
- [Drew] I didn't notice that!
- It doesn't wrinkle!
- I kept watching, I was like,
"It's gonna wrinkle, it's gonna-
"No, it's not wrinkling.
"No, it's not wrinkling."
- I wore that dress for
three or four days straight.
I only took it off at lunch.
- [Drew] It's so beautiful.
- [Morena] They only
pressed it once in the day.
Anyway, to go on about
what the show is about,
she gets captured and even though my means
of going about things
are potentially illegal
and a little questionable,
what I want is justice and truth.
And revenge for what
happened to my family,
which was orchestrated
somehow by the US government,
which you'll come to find out.
I'm probably giving out a lot of secrets
I shouldn't.
- No, this is so good!
I'm sorry to say, it sounds sick,
but everybody loves revenge.
- [Morena] Yes.
(audience laughs)
- They do!
(audience applauds)
- Yes.
It's healthy.
It's a healthy dose.
- It's so true.
Well, I happened to be looking
at your Instagram page.
I hope that's okay.
- Of course.
- I'm cyber stalking you.
- It's there for the looking.
- Okay, good!
Well, we wanted to just do
a little quick deep dive with you
and see if we could ask you
some rapid fire questions
that we got from your profile.
- Okay.
- All right.
You call yourself a wine
maker, late night thinker.
What's the best idea you've ever had
while drinking wine at night?
- Having a third kid.
(Drew gasps)
(audience laughs)
- Okay, perfect.
Parlay with three kids
under the age of 10,
what is the best parenting
advice you've ever gotten?
- Just try to be good enough.
Don't try to be perfect.
(audience applauds)
- Okay.
As a Brazilian native,
what is your first stop
when you go back to visit?
- I go to these little kiosks that sell...
They're like, they're lined with fruits.
And you just make up a juice combination
and a grilled cheese sandwich.
- The grilled cheese!
- The grilled cheese is the best.
- [Drew] They're flat!
- It's the best.
- The best grilled cheese ever.
Well, thank you so much.
Morena, watch "The Endgame"
Monday nights on NBC.
And as usual, we'll be cheering you on.
- [Morena] Thank you.
- And admiring everything you do.
(audience applauds)
- [Morena] Thank you so much.
- We'll be right back.
(upbeat music)